he thought this was supposed to be the
most advanced security system on the
planet blizzcon 2016 kicked off today
and in one of the segments it confirmed
what a lot of us suspected Joey you are
a big overwatch player are you not yes I
am and we kind of got to see a few
rumors confirmed today one of which and
the major one was sombra as the next
character coming to my watch she is
actually not only is she revealed but
she will actually be on PTR playable for
all of us who aren't at blizzcon next
week for people who are at blizzcon they
can play it today and a lot of her
abilities that we soften its animated
short which I believe was called
infiltration it showed her Widowmaker
Reaper sneaking in to kill a Russian
leader and zaria showed up at the end
but basically the short confirmed what
we knew about her at least from the
leaks is that she's very like hacking
oriented and very like technologically
savvy she also like they showed her even
a submachine gun against a few ah miix
and Russian soldiers but she's gonna be
an attacker right she's kind of going to
be an offensive character that can you
know like judge on the short can kind of
deactivate things when she needs to and
also teleport if I'm not mistaken right
so a lot of her abilities actually
weren't shown in the trailer itself if
you go onto the website and you can get
runned out all her abilities which
include the teleporter which she can
actually throw in the air not just slide
on the ground as you saw on the short
her hacking ability will disable all
turrets such as tour of yours I'm not
sure about bashing but she can also why
pretty much anyone's ability that they
have up right at the moment and so her
oats will be EMP blast which will do
that for everyone within a certain
radius and so that's a pretty big for
getting in behind enemy lines and
shutting down the defense yeah so we
know sombras really good at D buffing
people right the activating shields and
kind of help making other offensive
characters like attack better so what
characters do you think she would work
well with on the offensive well first
time to mine is actually a sariah when
she does use for grabs and search it
pulls everyone in and a lot of times
what will happen is a bat or a Reinhardt
will be staying there with a shield up
and won't do anything so if you can shut
down every one of their buildings in
that bubble you can just go for the kill
right away cool yeah I mean I think she
could be like work well with any attack
really like Genji if he's in close in
the zone and trying to catch her like
she could just deactivate anybody's
shield so Ganges has free reign to like
just cut everybody up or McCree I guess
if he's using dead I or like anything
really that's offensively oriented I
think she would work really well with
him pretty excited to track around the
PTR yeah cool and the last thing i want
to touch on for people that are really
into the lure of over watches where's
somber fit into all this like as a
character who is she well she's part of
the gang los Muertos who you know again
infiltrated a lot of the loo miracle
corporation which took place and i think
it was in the Dorado map they had the
big pyramid building um and you know
asked after about six months worth of
arg games with blizzard sending everyone
on a wild-goose chase it's quite a nice
release to actually finally see her in
in the flesh yeah i'm definitely looking
forward to trying her on the PTR next
week and we do have people down at
blizzcon so hopefully they'll get the
chance to play hands-on with her there
she is playable down there if i'm not
mistaken and stay tuned again swap for
more blizzcon news we will have stuff
about diablo have stuff about new somber
character as it unfolds so stay tuned is
if i had the choice
now what friend I'll be in touch
you